if you guys don't actually know this if
you go back on to my YouTube there's a
sketch on there about Kim Jong Ella that
I had a friend on with Arden Cho
so as me and Arden Cho and she was
playing my wife and Muriel was a PA on
that set and that was the first time I
ever met her and it's caught on camera
the very first day that we ever met yes
that's true
and the first time I met you you know
when I first saw you you know I thought
to myself yeah like me I don't think
very anything about you I was working
yeah and I didn't really think much of
you too cuz you were wearing socks and
slippers
no slocked socks and flip-flops so I was
like what the hell I still have lots of
socks
not in front of me that that was the
first time that we met and then we met
us another time after that and is when
she decided to be a guest on our or a
cocoa star in one of my fake Korean Nike
commercials I was supposed to your mom
that was it that was it I was supposed
to be your mom and I just have supposed
to curse at you but I didn't want to
curse because I didn't know how to curse
in Korea so sigh can I just punch you
and you're like let's just try it and
then I went really well and next thing I
know you're like can you be my
girlfriend can you be my wife and I was
like and that's when you fell in love
and as I was like I feel so naked
that's fell in love with me it's amazing
man who she was she was she was all over
me dude all you saw could you couldn't
get enough of me dude you're like dude
who is this guy I have to say that you
were really funny and I was like man
he's gonna be a great friend if we keep
in touch but I never thought like more
than that okay why cuz I didn't know you
those are first time actually like first
time talking to each other cuz then the
first time we met we didn't speak to
each other yeah but the second time I
talked to you a lot you did I remember
what you were wearing to you're worrying
about white Johnny Depp blouse the
Pirates of the Caribbean white blouse
thank you oh right your your fire pants
as I call them well it's also recorded
in the video so yeah it's easy to
remember no I just remember because
a good boyfriend and I remember how cute
you were yeah and then you looked at me
and you're like who's this hunk of fat
Korean right there I was just like oh
you're actually funny cuz at first I was
like yours you seem like a douche bag
how did you even get how did you even
come to that conclusion
cuz you I mean no no no I didn't think
you're a douche bag it was just like oh
he's just I didn't think much of you and
then the second time see I'm like wow
this guy talks a lot and he's funny he's
nice I'm like that's cool that's cool
and then I remember we were in that room
alone right before we had our dinner and
I was mad flirting with you yeah that
was kind of scary I was like why you
holding my like somehow you held my
hands and I was like no okay so I was i
holding your hand i remember i was i was
just trying to like test you out of the
black suit if you'd and you kind of let
me know that oh she might kind of like
like me a little bit that's when i was
like no that's why I walked away cuz he
gave me that look and I like mmm that
look is kind of be me Oh Oh which means
I don't have to say it female female is
female like uh-uh not awkward like odd
he's on it mm-hmm
yeah but you still came back for some
more did I
well we're together aren't relationship
right now yeah that's true
yeah and then I realized you're actually
a nice guy but well I don't understand
what made you think I wasn't a nice guy
huh well it was my first time seeing you
you were so confident that I felt like
you thought he could get me right away
and I was like who do you think you are
thinking that you could get me right
away let's to be honest that's how I
felt was like this guy cuz you text me
after you're like oh you know I think we
should hang out and I'm like oh you
thought you know cuz I I was thinking
like oh you think I could get me right
away it's like as if so I said when I
said so i text you back and I was like
oh boot out go right yeah I think you
saw I was like oh you know we'll see but
for me I was like what I go yeah but you
still hit me back up though well so so
this is what happened so a few weeks
after that so what she did and she said
she didn't do this on purpose but I
think she did she left her watch at my
place she left this rose gold Cartier
watch at my place and I was like who
watch is this right and then I just
started asking around and I do Stan it
was from you and I was like this girl
Cinderella slippered my ass dude she
Cinderella's slipper my ass oh I'm just
gonna watch here and see and how'd you
just happen to leave it at my bedside
table oh because I would see it and hit
you back up you mean because we're doing
a bed scene so I had to leave it there
yeah that's what they always say you
left that in plain sight for me to see
and I think that I was like okay so she
trying to see me again so I got her
numbers and I was like okay
TIPA TIPA tap a type of type of type a'
what's up and then she had to see me
again because I had her watch and so we
met back a second time after that or
this is the third time at our friend's a
shallow spot that she was opening up in
k-town so when she opened up that spot
our mutual friend Edie was there and she
was there too and I was like cool I'll
see you there I decided to give her her
watch then and of course lo and behold I
asked when we were gonna hang out again
right and she gave me the same [ __ ]
answer which I could I mean we'll see so
she did that crap again but the reason
why there's a there's a funny moment too
in my Instagram if you guys look back
far back into my Instagram there's
actually a picture of her and this is a
picture of her holding the plate of
random vegetables so during the opening
right she did the most Asian thing so
she got invited as a guest and then
there was leftover vegetables and she
went up to my friend and she goes or
he's just gonna throw this away can I
take it home so she literally packages
up everybody's veggies to take it home
untouched veggies untouched messy
because they're gonna go to waste it's
like well I had gotten no food at home
might as well take home I mean less
trash for her right yeah and I was like
oh this is dope but I have to ask you
though when you cuz you put a hashtag is
as my future wife
yeah that was a joke that's kind of
ironic yeah that's it was a joke you
know and it means you know just because
I saw oh this girl's like super frugal
they're like that's a down-ass [ __ ]
that's what that's what I was thinking
in my head but after that so and I asked
her to like what are we gonna hang out
and you you you agree that we were
did you like me more cuz of that I don't
know if I liked you more but I thought
you were really really attractive then
you just had like something fun about
you I didn't know what it was yet and
mind you what you don't know is that
during that time too I wasn't thinking
about settling down or trying to be in a
really serious relationship some with
somebody until I was 30 hmm
so the age that I am now that's what I
was thinking okay I'm gonna like do some
serious dating until then I'll just
gonna date around mess around and just
do whatever
but until but prior to that I already
decided in my mind that hey I'm not
going to settle down with anybody mm-hmm
but then I saw you and I was like okay
well if I if I see something in this
person and I choose to ignore it because
I set up this rule for myself nobody
pressed that rule upon me I created that
rule in my own mind so I was like okay
well that's dumb this is an opportunity
and you should take it so I I decided to
pursue you and it took a very very long
time it was I kid you not from the
moment that I met her to our first date
which I say is our first date it took
about two and a half months it was like
two months to two and a half months yeah
because after that Shaba thing you
didn't hit me back up for like another
month you just disappeared you were not
busy you were interning at fullscreen
well I was hustling I was trying to find
my you know my future career at that
time did you know what you texted me
what like I didn't hit you up you hit me
up after a month yeah cuz that's when I
was like cuz I got really busy with the
project I was working on it and then
when I was coming towards to the end I
was like oh yeah I should probably hit
him up and you're like so when are we
gonna go out to eat yeah and a month
passed I was like a month passed you
were you gonna give up on me I already
moved on from you at that point really
because it or because I've already tried
once
no no multiple times I try when I first
met you right you didn't but you didn't
ask me out I technically did though I
hit you up and I was like you mean in a
passive way that wasn't how was that
passive you texted me you texted me once
I be like hey let's hang out that was
one time I was like you're really cool
we should hang out sometime
right and then there was the watch thing
that I hit you up again that's the best
white really you hooked me up twice no I
thought
one no the first the first time was
after the sketch and I had your watch
and I used that as a segue to ask you
well I was like Yolo we should hang out
let's list let's kick it let's listen
let's be around each other and then
you're like poor Jaggu
when I had your watch uh-huh so that's
why we saw each other again and then
after I gave you back your watch and we
had the shabu thing I asked again and
then you did that poach out who crap
again
really so I was in orange so I just
waited I don't want to pressure you
I already put myself out there twice so
at that point I'm begging yo if she
wants to hit me up the the balls in her
court
mm-hmm so I've already expressed how I
felt mm-hmm and then I was interested
and then you have a month later out of
Nohr so I was like who the hell is this
worried but you were still interested
like cool ooh let's try this out and
then we went on our very first date
what'd you say wasn't a date was day
okay how is a date if it was a place
where you didn't even like and I picked
the place and I came with my bicycle on
my gym outfit how is that a date though
like that wasn't a date to me that was
just more like let's really just oh my
god it's it's it's a meetup date the
kind of thing and we met it for dinner
yeah but it was like at a place I you
didn't like and we met up for dinner
and I got a frickin tick tick I got a
ticket that day coming to see you that
was a sign you should have known though
I'm not a date you're wearing this like
weird hat it was it was a goofy on it or
something but it was like eyeballs
it was eyeballs although I was like who
the hell is it that's exactly cuz it
wasn't a date for me it was just hey you
said let's hang out you didn't ask me
out on a date but we would I can't do be
more straightforward David well I wasn't
sure but it it wasn't like a very formal
date though but I was asking you out so
you have different kind of dates like
there's a formal there's like a date
where we go where we go out I buy you
dinner I probably dress up a little bit
this is like a it's like if you were on
a dating app right you meet up with that
person the first time you're probably
not gonna be dressed up all the way up I
wouldn't dress up the way I don't know
or at that point oh yeah I guess you
caught us truce off of me
yeah and I made it clear as possible
that I was interested in you so it
wasn't like I was you know what I mean
well that's the thing because I didn't
know you and I know yes like David the
comedian guy who you know has a lot of
attention yeah and I don't know how that
world
and if someone in that world all setting
gives me interest like I don't know this
guy's just playing around being serious
you know like but even if I wasn't
playing around being serious I clearly
wasn't trying to meet you up just to be
your friend right I don't know if you
just wanted to help that's that's your
problem too though well it's as a girl
you gotta be careful especially in that
know you you have to be careful right
but you're not careful like that with
other people I know what you're talking
about but I am careful line up where I
don't go to that extent you know like
you're not careful every time we've had
okay we'll bring that up in a yeah it's
so annoying but so anyways we meet up at
this place I think it was called Sage
Bistro yeah in place and the first thing
I did when I sat that I looked at I goes
are you vegan and she goes no like thank
God man this is this might work out okay
cuz the thing was that I was new to
Culver City right or the location and
you're like oh you know we should have a
dinner I'm like great you have a place
in mind in your life do you have any
place that you like and at that time I
was really into vegan stuff like
exploring the vegan food yeah so I was
like oh let's get vegan food then if you
don't know any place like I only know
one place each and you're like you text
me by like are you vegan yeah like just
like vegan food and you're like okay
then I can meet up with you but I didn't
know that you hated or you're not a big
fan of E I'm it's not that I'm not a big
fan of vegan food it's I don't like
vegan food that tries to be something
that it's not so for example like vegan
vegan pizza they use cashew cheese so
just don't use cheese like you don't
have to make something into something
else right unless it's like like
Buddhist Asian Vietnamese but they do a
really good job and you know why it's
because these monks for 10,000 years
we're working on this recipe so I'm
pretty sure they got a down pat you know
it's just I don't like American vegan
food a lot it just it tastes like
something that I shouldn't taste like
because they're trying to make it taste
like something else and that's what I
don't like yeah I guess so that that's
that's why I didn't like it but we met
up at the sage Bistro thing and then we
had a good time I remember you were
cracking up you are laughing I was
making you laugh you were laughing dude
I was like this girl's yeah of course
because you were laughing so hard it
just fell out of your memories and
and then you rode your bike and you're
like well I'm gonna bike home and it was
super late at night it was dark and I
was like no I'll drop you off and I just
got my jeans I know I'm Yugi and you had
a blanket for some reason because I was
moving stuff in and out into that
apartment in k-town and so I was like oh
well let's I'll drop you off just put
your bike in the car and it's not like
you just did it out of nowhere because
we already met before we have mutual
friends hmm you know so it wasn't like
too weird for me to say that we've met
twice you worked on my set twice so we
had we already had some whatever I feel
like a little bit iffy about it I mean
we met each other we were going back and
forth we had conversations on the phone
we met we know each other's friends we
had mutual friends so it's kind of like
it wasn't it wasn't a weird situation
for you it wasn't a random stranger so
that's why I took the offer if not but
like hell no I don't know you yeah and
so I dropped her off and this was the
funny thing too so I don't know what it
was prior to other guys that tried to
date you before but so when we were when
we were there and this is such an
interesting situation so she actually
noticed about me now but I'm a very very
very very straightforward person
I am I'm hyper straightforward like to
almost to a fault which is why I tend to
get in a lot of trouble because I don't
I've learned now to hold back a lot more
but and specifically just being in this
relationship has taught me to be very
careful about my words instead of just
saying what's on my mind all the time
which is dumb I yeah so when we were
when I was saying my goodbyes to her I
gave her a I was going for a hug which I
hug everybody
know that whether I like somebody or not
and I go for a hug and she gives me this
you know the crappy girl hug it's if
there's like a specific technique it's
like when you do a deadlift right you
just kind of like posture your shoulders
up you just spread out your chest a
little bit pass out and then she makes a
super stiff and she'd give me that tap
tap tap tap tap in the back Hank yeah a
little tap on the back and I got this
hug and I looked at her and the first
thing I said right off the bat was what
I call you to give me a better hug than
that I was like well I was like oh you
don't give very good hugs I was like oh
by the way we're not friends
oh okay I thought the straight-up oh
we're not friends and I remember you
were like what what do you
you're laughing and I was like we're not
friends I'm not trying to be your friend
we're dating that was a shock for me
because no one ever said that to me
before
none of the guys at least I was dating
or who wanted to be more than friends
they would never say that I had I mean I
don't know why so that was like actually
a shock because I didn't expect that I'd
even know like someone would ever say
that yeah